acusaciones contra el ex príncipe
heredero de un complot malicioso
destinado a desestabilizar el reino con
el apoyo de entidades extranjeras las
autoridades jordanas aseguran que el
príncipe hans a medio hermano del rey
abdalá ha estado buscando el apoyo de
líderes tribales en contra del gobierno
y las notas que hat la uer y a las
investigaciones iniciales han revelado
que personas cercanas al príncipe hamza
han pasado alegaciones y cartas a
partidos extranjeros incluida la si
llama a posición extranjera para
instarlos a trabajar contra la seguridad
nacional y distorsionados el truco para
este acto el ministro de exteriores
anunció que al menos otras 16 personas
han sido arrestadas acusadas de amenazar
la seguridad nacional anteriormente el
presidente del senado jordano dijo que
nadie está por encima de la ley
organiza siempre en el punto de mira
históricamente lo estamos hay partidos
extranjeros en el juego agitando la
estabilidad pero este es un país muy
arraigado jordan es un país muy
arraigado y consistente bajo el mandato
de su majestad el región
y el salvador príncipe hans ha difundido
un vídeo acusando a los gobernantes
jordanos de nepotismo y corrupción y a
los servicios de seguridad de abusos por
criticar todos estos aspectos afirmó
encontrarse bajo arresto domiciliario y
negó formar parte de una conspiración
admitió haber estado en contacto con la
gente para decirles que quiera jordania
y que es consciente de sus necesidades
por supuesto que esto es algo nuevo
nunca antes ha sucedido usualmente los
problemas de la familia real de que han
dentro de la familia por lo que es la
primera vez que tenemos este tipo de
acusaciones en público
washington los aliados del golfo y la
liga árabe fueron los primeros en
mostrar su apoyo al gobierno
prooccidental del rey abdalá visto como
una ancla de estabilidad en la región
más tarde la unión europea y rusia- han
expresado también su apoyo al rey y su
papel moderado en la región ante el
intento de desestabilizar la seguridad
jordana